[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps
est venu
le temps est venu
le temps est venu pour les 100 mêler les
Métis
les
êtres hétéroclites hybrides bariolées
ceux qui se sont toujours entendu dire
qu'ils ne sont pas dignes pas de dignes
d'être là pas de ligne de prendre la
parole pas de lignes tout simplement
d'exister
en raison de leur identité pluriel
ces êtres divergents que la société
adore détester
ce sont les mêmes que l'on retrouve dans
nos comptes et les jambes nos films et
des saints animés ils sont les Achille
les Moïse
les Arthur mais aussi les Batman et
Superman et tous les autres
l'espace curieux que la société et bien
adore c'est être divergents c'est héros
[Musique]
et dans le même temps et bien se refuse
de considérer tout ce qu'il y a de
divergent autour de nous dans notre
société
[Musique]
et oui peut-être l'avez-vous remarqué
vous même
notre monde est entouré de divergences
d'être divergent d'objets divergents
de façon de se conduire de manière
divergente
bienvenue à tous je m'appelle Nathanaël
Ramos et cet après-midi et bien nous
allons explorer un sujet qui touche
l'ensemble de nos interactions au
quotidien
la divergence
effectivement nous vivons dans un monde
où tout devient complexe et la réalité
est souvent comment est souvent
considéré comme étant fixe et immuable
mais il était vraiment
au fur et à mesure que nous intéressons
les uns avec les autres mais on se rend
compte que
la réalité du voisin est différent de
celle de la mienne nos perspectives
divergent nos opinions
diffèrent et je vais vous inviter et
bien pendant quelques minutes apprendre
à pas de côté pour reconsidérer comment
la raison et le chaos peuvent parfois
bien centre mêler
et comment accepter également l'altérité
l'incertitude
et comment cela peut nous aider
justement à naviguer dans un monde qui
est en constante mutations
le monde effectivement est devenu autre
le monde est devenu plus rien un petit
peu comme un smoothie
avec des ingrédients pris séparément qui
vont donner quelque chose de nouveau
à nouveau plus savoureux plus riche plus
onctueux quelque chose de plus nouveau
de plus riche de plus onctueux que
chacun justement de ces éléments pré
séparément
et c'est exactement ce dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui de plus de richesses
de plus de vie quelque chose qui va nous
égayer plus de fraîcheur plus de
diversité
pensez aux villes par exemple
le mariage entre la ville et la nature a
donné naissance à des fermes urbaines
des potagers sur les toits et pourquoi
pas demain on peut imaginer des élevages
d'animaux dont nos centres-villes
les entreprises elles ne sont pas au
reste elles se métamorphose elle aussi
elle nous propose des nouveaux produits
des nouveaux services qui n'existaient
pas encore il y a quelques années
engendrant ainsi il y a bien des
nouvelles façons de consommer des
nouvelles façons aussi de travailler
comme si on avait besoin et bien de
rajouter un petit peu de fun dans la
façon de travailler
et même les objets de notre quotidien et
bien participent à cette hybridation
comme certains philosophes d'appels
hybridation de la société
prenons un exemple tout simple un
téléphone
mais un téléphone me permet aujourd'hui
de faire de multiples choses bien sûr
évidemment des téléphones mais j'ai pu
aussi prendre des photos
faire des vidéos scannées je peux tout à
fait me mettre en scène partager sur les
réseaux sociaux des photos ou tout
simplement des vidéos sur un tx
on a simplement grâce à ses objets ces
extensions de nous-mêmes on a rajouté un
petit peu de polyvalence
la divergence la divergence est
exactement ce que la société a besoin
d'aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir se remettre sur des rails
un peu de folie un peu de mélange
c'est chose
tous ces êtres tous ces lieux c'est
sérieux et bien on a du mal à les ranger
dans tes quêtes dans différentes
catégories de fait de leur polyvalence
aujourd'hui notre réalité est devenue
indéfinissable
un qualifiable
et on sent quelque part dans notre fort
intérieur et bien que nous avons perdu
ce lien
qui nous tenait avec cette réalité
en fait la crise que nous traversons
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas une crise
économique
à une crise financière
pas une crise sanitaire
ce qui est en crise chez nous
[Musique]
et bien c'est notre rapport à la réalité
la réalité cette matière parfois
intangible mais parfois aussi si
tangible en même temps
et cette réalité a subi et bien
une radicalisation une transformation
énorme avec l'émergence des nouvelles
technologies les frontières entre le
réel et le virtuel s'estompe
on assiste aujourd'hui à une
métamorphose de la réalité on parle de
réalité métamorphe
et leur bien vous comprenez qu'on ne
peut plus se contenter que d'un seul
point de vue d'un seul principe
[Musique]
nous avons besoin d'une nous nourrir
de nouvelles dimensions
l'émergence des objets connectés qui
sont rentrés dans nos vies
l'Internet de l'objet et l'exemple
parfait de cette hybridation
les objets du quotidien j'en ai rappelé
avec le téléphone mais aussi la voiture
de domicile sont devenus
ultra connectés on peut même les
contrôler à distance et bien justement
cette fusion entre le monde réel et le
monde virtuel fausses questions elle a
affecté notre façon d'interagir les uns
avec les autres elle a affecté notre
manière d'interagir avec notre
environnement de manière globale
et elle aussi nous a permis et bien
d'ouvrir de nouvelles opportunités
d'élargir le choix de nos partenaires de
collaborer à une autre échelle
les nouvelles technologies ont également
infectées je dirais même jusqu'au
rapport à
on parle de relation
à distance on va maintenant émerger des
rapports des relations dites ouvertes
c'est pour vous montrer à quel point le
monde actuel a comment a connu de
bouleversement important
on parle même de réalité virtuelle
imaginez maintenant on parle de réalité
augmentée
dans ses plus vraiment qui est quoi ou
quoi et qui on ne sait plus vraiment
vous donner de la tête
ce qui est sûr par contre c'est que nous
sommes dans une illusion de monde
parallèle mais pourquoi ce besoin
d'illusion comme si notre quotidien ne
se suffisait pas lui-même comme si la
vie était devenue tellement monotone
tellement morte
que nous ressentons le besoin nous nous
réfugier dans des métaphes
en fin de compte il faut comprendre que
la réalité est beaucoup plus complexe
plus riche et ne l'est et c'est
justement cette complexité qui nous
pousse à explorer de nouveaux continents
de nouveaux territoires et il est temps
justement d'apprendre à saisir cette
réalité divergente pour mieux se
réapproprier
ces interactions qui en découlent
fin de compte c'est une divergence que
l'on constate tous n'est qu'en fait que
le miroir de notre propre complexité en
tant qu'être humain ce besoin qui que
nous avons tous d'aller conquérir des
territoires inconnus cette
émerveillement qui fait que la vie est
bien
vaut la peine d'être vécue
donc il est important d'accepter
d'intégrer cette divergence dans notre
vie quotidienne pour mieux nous aider à
naviguer dans ce monde encore une fois
qui est en constante évolution
alors parfois on peut être dérouté
il est nécessaire dans certains cas bien
de prendre
un pas de côté
pour mieux analyser mieux comprendre
comment les interactions sont en train
de se nouer
et pour cela bien je vais utiliser une
analogie celle du jardinier
imaginez un jardinier qui a fait dans
son jardin en train d'arroser
religieusement ses plantes
désherbées avec précaution son potager
et bien il est tellement concentré dans
son activité et bien qu'il a perdu le
lien lui aussi avec son environnement il
a perdu le lien avec la beauté de son
jardin il ne voit plus les couleurs
éclatantes des fleurs les formes
de ces arbustes
les interactions complexes qui se nous
entre la nature les oiseaux les insectes
et ses plantes
et bien dans ce cas-là il peut être
nécessaire pour ce jardinier de reculer
de prendre un pas de côté
de prendre le temps
de s'asseoir peut-être sur un banc
et d'observer de prendre une vision
d'ensemble sur son jardin
de voir comment les différents éléments
et bien
se nourrissent les uns des autres
comment toutes les parties fonctionnent
entre elles voir les nuances de couleurs
qui n'avaient pas vu auparavant
et bien pour nous être humain c'est la
même chose
nous devons parfois bien prendre du
recul par rapport par rapport à nos
interactions que nous avons dans le
quotidien
pris dans le quotidien dans ce vraiment
ce tourbillon et bien parfois on perd le
sens des réalités
ces petits gestes qui nous touchent
les mots ils sont utilisés qui résonnent
en nous
ce silence
ça aussi et
effectivement pas partie de nos
interactions
et pour mieux comprendre nos
interactions et bien il est nécessaire
de prendre justement un temps de recul
quitte à s'isoler moi par exemple Marie
lorsque je suis en conflit avec un de
mes proches de prendre ce temps
nécessaire parce que
j'ai perdu en fait l'utilité de la
conversation prise dans mes arguments
j'ai oublié de prendre en considération
l'autre partie ces émotions
la perspective
et c'est tout à fait normal
d'avoir négligé parfois de temps à autre
le point de vue de l'autre
il est nécessaire et bien de prendre du
recul pour mieux analyser cette
situation
et il est certain que
quand nos relations à l'autre c'est
inévitable
et bien sont confrontés confrontés à
l'altérité confronté à l'incertitude
et dans ce genre de situation et bien on
peut se retrouver quelques petits munis
perdu
et puissant
comme si le monde le monde qui nous
entoure et bien s'écroulait
bien dans ces moments-là
il faut accepter
il faut accepter de baisser les bras et
de rendre les armes et moi même dans ces
moments-là j'ai du mal parce que j'ai
l'égo qui rentre en jeu qui veut essayer
il se nourrit de cette espèce de
confrontation
et à mon époque j'ai très souvent voulu
tout maîtriser tout contrôler tout
réguler
pourquoi
pour éviter les surprises
et déceptions et être triste et être
malheureux
et paradoxalement et bien cela
nourrissait mon état d'anxiété interne
vous stresse et c'est là que j'ai
compris que quelque chose me manquait
c'est quelque chose a bien ce sont les
rendez-vous ratés les imprévus les aléas
de la vie qui font encore une fois que
la vie mérite d'être vécue et donc j'ai
appris à être plus ouvert d'esprit
et à faire preuve de lâcher prise
et c'est ce que nous enseigne
effectivement
les traditions stoïciennes à prendre du
recul sur les événements ne pas se
laisser emporter par nos émotions que ce
soit la colère ou la tristesse
en effet
le lâcher prise et la sagesse stoïcienne
sont peut-être des choses qui sont
difficiles à mettre en place parce que
elles induisent des changements de
comportement des changements d'état
d'esprit
et ce qui est sûr c'est que avant nous
permettre de mieux comprendre nos
interactions et ne pas se laisser
balloter par les événements extérieurs
en fin de compte et pour conclure je
dirais que oui nous vivons dans un monde
qui est difficile
d'être parce que nous devons à chaque
fois nous adapter nous sommes dans un
monde qui est
constante évolution on constante
mutation et il est plus
souvent nécessaire de prendre ce fameux
pas de côté encore faut-il prendre le
temps
le temps au temps de manière à mieux
comprendre les interactions qui nous
entourent
la vie est quelque part comme une espèce
de symphonie chaque note de musique
participe à cette mélodie
participe à cette harmonie
et que parfois il n'est pas besoin de
s'attacher à telle ou telle note et
plutôt la laisser partir pour lui
laisser la place pour vivre de nouvelles
expériences
conclurai en disant que
il y a des choses qui sont dans notre
contrôle il y a des choses que nous
pouvons absolument pas contrôler donc
focalisons nous sur le ici et maintenant
et acceptons que il y a des choses que
nous pouvons pas gérer
ce que je vous invite à faire c'est si
vous le voulez c'est prendre une
profonde inspiration en mettant votre
main sur le cœur
soufflez profondément
et lâcher prise
lâcher prise
osez vous ouvrir à l'inconnu et
croyez-moi vous aurez de belles
surprises merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]